e aí a gente perguntava você pois ela é
o outro foi no cinema e como é que eu
fui ao cinema um espectro que foi meu
namorado manda mensagem a um cinema um
bom no cinema romântico quinho não pensa
em trocar salinas todo 28 passando muito
pensando no outro passando a bola voltou
a assistir um filme bem legal zinho
chega no cinema vamos assistir o que ana
bely eu não tenho medo de filme de
terror porque filme de terror filme
bonequinha assistir um filme e televisão
cqc anabela e não é um fim é
aterrorizante é um filme dá susto ele é
um filme assustador que tocou de cabeça
pela linha assustador o piano é pai é um
filme que tem uma boneca e tem um
demônio e o demônio e quer a filha do
casal ea ele usa a boneca para poder
chegar até o filho casado pelo demônio
eles acordaram uma coisa pra poder
chegar até o objetivo dele é o nome do
filme annabelle cpi a boneca vai ainda
pagar vou matar você conecta um fator
raminho é o fim tony assim ó fala meu
deus de aumento na casa da correcta
matando g1 bem muito perto me correr na
casa do povo bancada de cada boneco na
velha balançando na cadeira na velha com
rádio banda b
triste annabelle aterrorizante fumar
maconha
a gente é aberta a boneca não faz nada
quem faz é o demônio é o filme todo é a
boneca parada ea câmera dando um zoom na
casa na perna tá é isso pode agora esse
susto meu amigo é uma horda que a moça
vai fazer
[Música]
a gente é cada sul
agora outra porque assustado demônio que
no filme tem demônio capa-preta capiroto
tranca rua zé pilintra coisa ruim e tem
hora que aparece uma cena a mulher olha
pra alguém assim
ele fala no céu bem dessa pedra 90 que
ele volta a ser gente regula gente era
um bicho fim 36 uma coisa feia meu deus
do céu e imagem negócio tão fake por um
cílio chegar a participação especial na
região da casa até a hora que tem uma
criancinha vij branca a minha começa a
correr lá possa ganhar maria bethânia
concorre a 50 no interior de filme de
terror filme terror porque é que o dia
parece que tem três horas e à noite tem
75 é tudo e noite é a pessoa que está no
filme terror e insiste em ficar sozinhos
eu quero da boneca com damon demônio
perseguindo fica de noite tudo escuro a
pessoa que inventa que ela tem que ir no
banheiro ea gente está acontecendo
coisas muito a sua vida fica no seu
quarto fica em cima da cana coloque sua
proteção martos mundial que é o seu
cobertor que vocês sabe o monterrey bota
dentro de seu carro se comportou
cobertor fala muito fala [ __ ] bicho de
carne amanhã eu volto a única coisa que
tenho raiva de colocar a cobertura para
proteger o monstro que toda vez que
penso na minha campanha bota o cobertor
quando horta onde o projeto cantando em
baixo o que dá uma raiva eu quero que
você me conta o que é que você tem mais
medo de filme de terror começa aqui em
baixo e não esquece você está no youtube
que daqui gosto que me ajudou demais se
você tiver no facebook que lilic
ultimamente está todo 10 mil líquidos 11
mil você chama de parabéns e muito
obrigado e espero pessoalmente então
curtir no facebook está no twitter da rt
no twitter facebook estava tudo aqui na
descrição do vídeo e quiser me seguir
pra nunca mais perderam um vídeo se
inscreve no canal também beleza é nós
falou e cuidado pra nada e por que não
aqui é muito susto a melhor pessoa para
tal